"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Niagalé Bagayoko,
l'Afrique,
dont certains ont dit
qu'elle n'était pas rentrée
dans l'histoire,
elle a toujours été
un enjeu géostratégique, non ?
-Absolument, on l'a vu
à l'époque
de la colonisation,
donc au 19e siècle,
ce fameux "scramble for Africa",
le partage de l'Afrique.
-Rappelez ce que c'est ?
-Le congrès de Berlin.
-En 1885.
-Exactement.
Qui a présidé
au partage du continent
entre les grandes
puissances européennes.
-Principalement,
l'Angleterre...
-Et la France.
Et l'Allemagne,
dans une moindre mesure.
Une part du gâteau
beaucoup moins importante.
On l'a vu également
dans le courant du 20e siècle,
avec la part prise
par les Africains,
dans les 2 guerres mondiales.
Et enfin, on l'a vu,
durant la guerre froide,
où l'affrontement bipolaire
s'est également joué
sur le continent.
-Sous influence russe,
soviétique.
Et des pays
sous influence occidentale.
Notamment américaine.
Et française.
-Absolument.
Même si,
comme aujourd'hui,
à mon avis,
le choix des camps différents
n'était pas aussi
tranché qu'on pouvait
aussi bien le dire.
La force diplomatique
des Etats africains
a souvent été de jouer
sur les concurrences internationales
et de se positionner soit
dans un camp soit dans l'autre.
Mais, également dans le cadre
du mouvement des non-alignés.
-Justement, à la faveur
du conflit en Ukraine,
avec l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie, y a eu des votes.
Deux votes aux Nations unies
et stupeur
et tremblements,
beaucoup d'Etats africains,
notamment à l'occasion
du 1er vote en mars,
qui, soit,
n'ont pas condamné l'invasion,
soit, se sont abstenus.
Certains, ça a été étonnant,
comme le Sénégal, la 1ère fois,
ou le Congo-Brazaville, les 2 fois.
Ils ont refusé de condamner.
Donc, ça veut dire que là,
aujourd'hui,
c'est quand même
encore une façon
de dire : "Nous, on veut pas
rentrer dans ce conflit,
"on ne veut pas être alignés."
Ca veut dire ça ?
-Absolument.
-"C'est pas notre affaire."
-"Ce n'est pas notre affaire."
Mais aussi,
il faut tenir compte
de l'histoire
de chacun des pays
vis-à-vis de chacun
des 2 camps.
Si on prend un pays
comme l'Afrique du sud,
sa position s'explique
par le fait...
-Elle ne condamne pas.
-Elle n'a pas condamné.
Par le fait que
la lutte anti-apartheid
a toujours été soutenue
par l'Union soviétique.
A l'époque.
Dans le cas du Sénégal,
Macky Sall était à l'époque
président de l'Union africaine.
Et étant donné l'absence
d'unité de position
de tous les membres
de l'organisation,
il a refusé de se positionner.
Donc, au-delà de cette absence
de soutien à un camp ou à l'autre,
je pense qu'il est très important
de rentrer aussi dans le détail
des positions de chacun.
-On est dans l'esprit
dans la conférence de Bandung ?
C'est une grande conférence,
qui a eu lieu
en 1955 en Indonésie,
dans laquelle
certaines grandes figures
de l'histoire ont marqué
leur empreinte.
Nehru, et beaucoup
d'autres présidents.
On est dans cet esprit ?
-Alors, à mon avis,
on est dans quelque chose
de différent.
On est dans une période,
où les Etats africains
ont décidé de multiplier
leurs partenaires.
Au-delà des relations
que ceux-ci peuvent
entretenir entre eux.
Aujourd'hui,
la plupart des diplomaties
africaines revendiquent
d'affirmer avant tout
leurs intérêts propres,
et non pas de s'aligner
sur des problématiques
qui ne les concernent pas
directement.
Aujourd'hui, il y a
une grande ouverture,
une grande compétition,
bien entendu, entre un bloc
qu'on peut qualifier
d'anti-occidental
et un bloc occidental.
Egalement à l'intérieur
de chacun de ces blocs.
On aurait tort, à mon avis,
de ne pas se rendre compte
qu'aujourd'hui,
certains pays européens,
par exemple,
se présentent aussi
comme des offres alternatives
à celle qui a été celle
des partenaires traditionnels.
donc je pense qu'on est
dans quelque chose d'assez nouveau
où les Etats africains
affirment leur souveraineté
et leur priorité accordée
à leurs propres intérêts.
-Est-ce que,
dans cette volonté
de non-alignement,
vous ressentez
un sentiment anti-occidental
qui est en train
de se développer ?
-A l'évidence, oui.
C'est extrêmement frappant.
On parle, bien entendu,
beaucoup du rejet
dont fait l'objet la France.
-On va en parler après.
-Vous avez raison de l'inscrire
dans un cadre plus large
qui va au-delà du rejet
des Etats occidentaux,
qui touche également les acteurs
non étatiques. Aujourd'hui,
il y a un discours assez violent
de rejet, par exemple,
des organisations
non gouvernementales occidentales.
-Ah oui ?
-Absolument,
auxquelles on reproche...
-Donc des ONG ?
-Des ONG
auxquelles on reproche
de monopoliser
les financements
au détriment des ONG
nationales et locales,
auxquelles on reproche
de promouvoir des normes,
des standards
et des principes
qui vont à l'encontre
de la culture du continent.
Ce rejet touche également
le système multilatéral
dans son ensemble,
notamment le système onusien,
au nom des normes
et des standards
qui sont présentés comment étant
souvent appliqués
de manière partiale
au continent africain.
-Vous voulez dire qu'il y a
un développement d'une africanité,
c'est ça ? C'est quoi ?
Ou un panafricanisme
particulier, non ?
-Alors...
C'est tout à fait
important
de distinguer africanité
et panafricanisme
parce qu'en effet,
il y a cette revendication
d'une africanité
et de la mise en avant
des spécificités du continent
et de son contexte.
D'un autre côté, il y a
effectivement ce mouvement
qu'on peut qualifier
de néo-panafricaniste
qui promeut une vision
extrêmement patriotique,
voire nationaliste,
et de rejet virulent.
Je pense que ceux qui revendiquent
leur africanité
ne se situent pas nécessairement
dans une confrontation
avec le monde occidental,
à l'inverse de ceux qui,
aujourd'hui, se revendiquent
du panafricanisme.
-Style Kémi Séba.
-Absolument, et dont la vision
est en réalité
assez éloignée
de celle des pères...
-Du panafricanisme.
-...du panafricanisme
originel.
-D'accord. Est-ce que...
Alors, il y a une chose
qui polarise pas mal l'attention,
notamment en France, aujourd'hui,
c'est ce qui se passe au Sahel,
dans la bande sahélienne,
avec cette...
Cette arrivée des Russes
et notamment
de la milice Wagner
entretenue par un homme
qui s'appelle Prigozhin,
qui est un homme
qui est assez proche
de Vladimir Poutine,
et un sentiment anti-français
qui est
très violent.
Ce sentiment anti-français,
est-ce qu'il est dû
seulement au fait
que les militaires français
sont accusés de ne pas avoir
éradiqué, d'une certaine façon,
le djihadisme ?
-Je pense que ce sentiment
a de multiples causes.
Bien entendu,
l'incapacité qui a été celle
de l'opération Barkhane,
mais finalement,
de tous les acteurs
internationaux présents
à juguler la poussée du terrorisme
et de ses groupes djihadistes
est la première explication,
mais il y a également
la façon
dont l'analyse du conflit
s'est heurtée
à une vision stratégique locale
complètement divergente.
On a beaucoup mis l'accent
sur, justement,
cette lutte,
cette volonté d'éradiquer
les groupes terroristes
alors que si l'on prend
les autorités maliennes,
ce qui les préoccupait beaucoup,
c'était la tentative de sécession
des groupes touaregs au nord
qui se sont alliés
avec les Français,
ce qui a été perçu
comme une trahison.
-Des conflits de territoires.
-Des conflits de territoires
et des conflits communautaires
également.
Il y a eu aussi des attitudes
qui ont été perçues
comme absolument
insupportables
et d'une arrogance
qui est désormais rejetée
qui explique aussi ce rejet :
la convocation de Pau,
dont on parle souvent,
par Emmanuel Macron.
-La convocation,
dans la ville de Pau,
de chefs d'Etat africains,
c'était il y a deux-trois ans...
-Exactement.
-...pour leur dire un peu
leurs quatre vérités.
-Absolument.
-On sent qu'ils étaient à la tête
d'armées pas très fiables.
-Absolument, et qui a été perçu
comme irrespectueuse,
y compris par les opinions
publiques, qui contestaient
ces chefs d'Etat.
Il y a également
le deux poids, deux mesures
dans la politique française
que l'on reproche
aujourd'hui
et dont l'incarnation
est la position
vis-à-vis du Tchad,
dont le président actuel
a encore été reçu
à l'Elysée.
Lorsque l'on voit
les réactions en Afrique,
c'est une incompréhension,
parfois forcée,
instrumentalisée,
mais très souvent sincère :
pourquoi, alors qu'on est
face à un régime
inconstitutionnel
composé de militaires,
qui plus est dirigé par le fils
d'un président décédé,
dans le cadre
d'une transition dynastique,
on condamne les juntes...
-Le fils d'Idriss Déby.
-Oui, en l'occurrence,
on condamne les juntes
au Mali,
dans une moindre mesure
au Burkina Faso
ou en Guinée,
mais pas au Tchad ?
Et ça, ça fait aussi partie
des incompréhensions,
en tout cas des reproches
qui sont formulés
par les opinions publiques
envers la France.
-Le prétexte invoqué,
qui n'est pas un prétexte,
d'ailleurs,
qui est une raison
invoquée à Paris, enfin
qui est un peu mise de côté,
c'est de dire
que l'armée tchadienne
est très présente dans la lutte
contre le djihadisme,
là où les armées
burkinabée et malienne
sont beaucoup plus faibles
et beaucoup moins importantes
dans le dispositif
de Barkhane.
-A titre personnel,
je récuse totalement
cette analyse.
L'armée tchadienne
est extrêmement impliquée
dans la lutte contre
la secte islamiste Boko Haram,
du côté du bassin
du lac Tchad.
-D'accord,
en Afrique centrale.
-Oui, donc de l'autre côté
du Sahel,
mais en dehors
de l'intervention en 2013
aux côtés de la force Serval
où, en effet,
les Tchadiens ont joué
un rôle absolument majeur,
le Tchad a toujours négocié
de manière extrêmement ardue
sa participation à la lutte
contre le terrorisme
dans le Sahel central,
et sa principale illustration
en la matière
a été son déploiement
dans l'ouest du Niger,
où il y a eu des accusations
très graves de viol
contre ces soldats.
Donc attention à ce qu'on définit
comme une armée.
Une armée de guerriers
n'est pas
une armée professionnelle de soldats
nécessairement.
-Vous qui êtes
d'origine malienne,
c'est important,
comment voyez-vous
l'arrivée des Russes,
en plus de façon
non officielle ?
C'est pas Moscou, c'est pas
la diplomatie de Moscou,
c'est une milice,
certes très proche du régime,
mais qui s'installe :
Centrafrique, Mali,
peut-être Burkina Faso,
peut-être ailleurs,
en tous les cas,
qui tisse
des réseaux d'influence,
pas uniquement
en Afrique francophone.
Comment vous sentez ça ?
-Moi, je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse dissocier
la société militaire privée Wagner,
j'insiste sur ce terme,
parce que
l'une des difficultés
à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
est le statut juridique flou
de cette organisation...
-Vous êtes spécialiste
de ces questions.
-...qui n'est pas
uniquement investie
sur le terrain militaire,
mais qui est investie
dans le domaine médiatique,
dans le domaine minier, etc.
Donc il est à mon avis difficile
de la qualifier uniquement
comme un groupe mercenaire
ou milicien
et, qui plus est,
qui a des liens,
difficiles à démontrer
mais avérés,
avec l'Etat russe.
-Avec des voyages répétés
du ministre
des Affaires étrangères
Sergueï Lavrov
en Afrique.
-Exactement.
Il y a encore cette visite
qui vient de se dérouler,
du ministre Lavrov,
au Mali, en Mauritanie,
il ne faut pas l'oublier
également,
où a été réaffirmée la force
de la relation bilatérale.
On est vraiment
dans un partenariat bilatéral
affiché, affirmé,
où l'on ne reconnaît pas
forcément
le type d'acteurs
qui sont sur le terrain.
D'ailleurs, Vladimir Poutine
et Sergueï Lavrov
ont reconnu
que le groupe privé Wagner
était présent au Mali,
ce que dénient totalement
les autorités locales.
Mais au-delà de ça,
ce qui est important de voir,
c'est que la Russie
aujourd'hui
réactive,
en tout cas au Mali,
et dans une moindre mesure
au Burkina Faso,
des réseaux très anciens
dont elle disposait
dans les années 60...
-Du temps de l'Union soviétique.
-...jusqu'à la chute
de l'Union soviétique.
La coopération militaire
et de défense
a été extrêmement poussée,
extrêmement étroite.
Il y a eu
de très nombreux échanges,
notamment d'envoi de militaires
ou de civils également
en Union soviétique
ou dans les autres Républiques
soviétiques...
-Notamment
à l'université Lumumba
à Moscou.
-Et il y a encore
aujourd'hui
un grand nombre de locuteurs
russophones au Mali.
Donc il y a cette réactivation
de réseaux de l'époque,
qui plus est
avec cette rhétorique
anti-impérialiste
qui était aussi présente
du temps
de la Guerre froide.
-Les communistes.
-Exactement,
mais avec des techniques
d'aujourd'hui,
notamment via les réseaux sociaux,
mais pas uniquement.
On parle beaucoup de ça.
Le rapport à la presse locale
est extrêmement développé.
-Vous voulez dire
que la presse est noyautée
par Moscou ?
-Elle n'est pas noyautée.
En tout cas, au Sahel,
on ne peut pas dire ça.
En Centrafrique,
certains médias le sont.
En tout cas,
elle est pénétrée
par ces réseaux russes.
-Il y avait les sommets
France-Afrique,
qui n'ont pas
tout à fait disparu,
mais qui ont
changé de forme.
Maintenant,
on a des sommets
Russie-Afrique.
Le premier
a eu lieu à Sotchi,
une ville qui est chère
à Vladimir Poutine, en 2019.
Un sommet va se dérouler
en juillet prochain.
Normalement,
c'est un rendez-vous annuel
qu'a organisé la Russie.
Ca veut dire qu'à la place
de la Françafrique,
on va avoir bientôt
la Russafrique ?
-Oui, absolument.
-Après avoir parlé
de la Chinafrique.
-C'est exactement
ce que j'allais mentionner.
Il y a des sommets
France-Afrique,
des sommets Russie-Afrique,
des sommets Chine-Afrique,
des sommets Inde-Afrique,
des sommets Turquie-Afrique.
Il y a des sommets
Europe-Afrique également.
Il y a eu un sommet
très récemment...
-A Washington.
-...Etats-Unis-Afrique.
Donc je pense que
ce que l'on a mal mesuré,
en réalité, au cours des 10 années
qui se sont écoulées,
c'est que
le continent africain
a intéressé
un nombre croissant
d'acteurs non occidentaux
ou non européens,
puisqu'on a longtemps
considéré aussi
que c'était...
-Oui, chasse gardée.
-Voilà, que c'était
une chasse gardée,
mais des relations,
notamment
d'un point de vue économique,
se sont développées
avec d'autres partenaires,
et on découvre aujourd'hui
que l'Afrique est investie
dans une diplomatie
non occidentale.
-C'est ce qui fait dire
que l'Afrique est
le continent de l'avenir,
là où on vient chercher
des richesses ?
-Ca, je n'en suis pas
convaincue.
Je pense que la plupart
des continents
ont de très grandes
potentialités,
au-delà de la seule Europe
et des seuls Etats-Unis.
Ce qui est certain,
c'est que l'Afrique,
aujourd'hui,
pèsera plus économiquement
que ce qui a été le cas
jusqu'ici,
mais elle a quand même
un grand nombre de handicaps,
notamment
en matière de sécurité.
Il y a quand même
une insécurité
qui se diffuse
sur le continent
et qui est particulièrement
préoccupante.
-Comment vous expliquez...
Des villes où on se promenait
facilement,
comme Abidjan,
encore pire, Nairobi,
maintenant,
c'est des villes
un peu à l'image
de ce qui se passe
en Afrique du Sud.
C'est compliqué
de circuler
si vous êtes pas
barricadé et protégé.
-Côté kenyan, ça,
très certainement.
Il y a eu
une sorte de mouvement
de type ville américaine,
quelque part,
avec une privatisation
notamment
de la sécurité privée
des individus.
Dans l'Afrique occidentale,
de l'Ouest, en tout cas,
et centrale, à mon avis,
on n'en est pas encore là,
même s'il y a de nombreuses
compagnies de sécurité.
C'est plutôt une criminalité
moins importante
que l'on constate
dans ces villes,
mais qui, en effet,
rend beaucoup plus difficile
qu'à une certaine époque
le fait de se déplacer
librement.
-Certains disent
que c'est le continent
de l'avenir,
le continent du 21e siècle.
C'est un continent
truffé de richesses,
notamment les richesses
du sous-sol,
on peut pas le nier,
et néanmoins,
un des fléaux
de ce continent,
c'est aussi
que les Africains
quittent l'Afrique.
Et souvent, contrairement
à ce que les gens croient,
c'est pas les plus miséreux.
-Absolument pas.
-C'est les classes moyennes,
c'est les plus éduqués.
-Oui, absolument.
Il y a ce mouvement
qui est à la fois
un signe d'ouverture du continent
vers l'extérieur,
de sa mondialisation,
en réalité,
mais qui, en effet,
contribue
à une fuite des cerveaux
que l'on constate.
En Europe, on est familier
de ce phénomène,
puisque c'est identifié
au problème migratoire,
mais d'autres régions
du monde
le voient différemment.
Il y a un nombre impressionnant
d'Africains
qui ont gagné les Amériques,
qu'il s'agisse du Canada,
des Etats-Unis,
et qui ont plutôt réussi,
qui ont constitué
des diasporas
assez conséquentes,
mais effectivement,
c'est quelque chose
qui nuit au développement local
de ces élites.
Cela dit, un grand nombre
d'entre elles choisissent
souvent d'y revenir.
Même s'il y a un exil au départ,
il y en a de plus en plus
qui choisissent aussi
d'investir ensuite
dans un certain nombre
de domaines sur le continent.
-Il y a aussi tous les fléaux
qui expliquent aussi la migration.
C'est le réchauffement climatique,
c'est les problèmes de santé,
d'alimentation,
c'est une démographie galopante,
et on sait absolument pas
si les pays sont en mesure
de pouvoir assurer
la vie de toutes ces populations.
Il y a un manque
de structures phénoménal.
-Oui
et c'est là que l'on voit le rapport
avec l'extérieur.
En matière de santé,
on le sait très peu ici,
mais le principal partenaire,
c'est l'Inde,
qui a développé sa relation
avec le continent
autour de l'industrie
du médicament.
C'est très intéressant.
-Il y a beaucoup d'Indiens
qui résident en Afrique de l'Est.
-Oui,
et l'Inde s'inscrit elle aussi
aujourd'hui
dans cette dynamique
en partie anti-occidentale
en invoquant les liens
de Mahatma Gandhi,
notamment, avec l'Afrique...
-Il est né en Afrique du Sud.
-Absolument.
-A Durban.
-Exactement.
...et donc du rôle
que l'Afrique a joué
dans ce combat anti-impérialiste
dans lequel l'Inde se reconnaît.
Mais dans le domaine
de la santé,
il y a des acteurs
américains majeurs.
Le rôle de la fondation
Bill et Melinda Gates
est absolument énorme
sur le continent africain.
Donc on voit que les problèmes
du continent l'handicapent
mais créent aussi
des opportunités d'échange
avec les partenaires extérieurs,
y compris privés.
-Alors,
le pape François, qui était
il y a pas très longtemps
en République démocratique du Congo,
à Kinshasa, où il a été
très bien accueilli,
a eu un discours assez fort
en disant :
"Otez vos mains
"de ce continent", en parlant
à tous ceux qui veulent
jouer les prédateurs.
Est-ce qu'il a encore une voix
importante en Afrique ?
Sur un continent où il y a
deux phénomènes religieux
qui se produisent :
la monté de l'islamisme...
-Oui, et l'évangélisme.
-...et aussi
la montée de l'église évangélique.
-Absolument, le rôle des acteurs
religieux sur le continent africain
est absolument majeur.
On parle beaucoup, en effet,
des acteurs musulmans,
mais la façon dont les églises
évangélistes pullulent
dans toutes les régions
du continent,
en Afrique anglophone
comme en Afrique francophone...
-Et en Afrique du nord.
-Oui.
C'est absolument phénoménal,
en réalité.
Et c'est vrai
que l'église catholique,
aujourd'hui,
porte quand même une voix
qui est entendue,
notamment en Afrique centrale,
parce qu'elle s'est souvent
positionnée d'un point
de vue politique.
-Ah oui ?
-Tout à fait.
Le rôle de la conférence
des évêques,
en République
démocratique du Congo
a été majeur pour s'élever,
notamment,
contre les tentatives
de Joseph Kabila...
-L'ancien président de la RDC.
-Oui,
auquel a succédé
à Etienne Tshisekedi.
Donc le rôle de l'église catholique
dans la démocratisation
a été majeur.
Au Burkina Faso, il a joué
un rôle très important aussi.
Mais c'est vrai
qu'il faut, aujourd'hui, compter
avec ces acteurs religieux
qui sont de plus en plus politiques.
-C'est dangereux ?
-En tout cas, ce qui est certain,
c'est que l'idée d'un Etat
totalement sécularisé
est quelque chose
qui à mon avis recule beaucoup
sur le continent africain,
quelle que soit la foi
à laquelle adhère
le plus grand nombre.
-Je disais que vous aviez
des origines maliennes.
Vous êtes
une Française métisse.
Le métissage, en Afrique,
c'est quelque chose
qui est compliqué ?
-C'est perçu différemment...
-Et partout, d'ailleurs.
-Moi, je l'ai jamais vécu
comme quelque chose de compliqué
parce que mon parcours fait
que je ne me suis jamais
sentie stigmatisée nulle part,
ni ici ni là-bas.
-Il y a un homme qui a beaucoup
parlé du métissage,
c'est lui.
-Bien sûr.
-Il était pas métisse, d'ailleurs.
Alors il était autre chose.
Il était catholique
dans un pays à 95 % musulman.
-Donc Senghor,
grande figure de la négritude.
Donc moi, je ne l'ai jamais vécu
de manière négative.
En Afrique...
-Pas négatif,
mais difficile, quoi.
-Ni difficile.
Mais il faut savoir qu'en Afrique,
je suis perçue
comme quelqu'un de blanc,
et ici, comme quelqu'un de noir,
bien entendu.
-D'où la difficulté.
-Je l'ai jamais vécu
comme un difficulté
parce que je pense que chacun
a ses différences.
On peut être gros,
on peut être roux,
on peut être
avec une jambe en moins,
et chacun arrive à se construire
dans cette différence.
L'important, c'est d'être
dans un environnement
dans lequel
on a la possibilité
d'exister tel que l'on est.
J'ai toujours ressenti ça
aussi bien en France
que sur le continent africain.
-Ce métissage
qui se voit sur votre peau,
est-ce que c'est un métissage
qui se retrouve dans votre formation
culturelle ?
-En tout cas, ce qui me paraît
extrêmement important,
c'est d'être capable
d'avoir un amour
pour son propre pays,
qui est la France,
qui peut être absolu,
ce qui est mon cas,
sans être exclusif.
Je pense que l'exigence
qui est faite aujourd'hui
d'un choix en matière
d'affirmation
d'une identité est quelque chose
qu'en tout cas,
je refuse à titre personnel,
et qu'on peut totalement
se sentir appartenir à la nation
dans laquelle on est né.
Moi, ma mère était corse.
Ca ne se voit pas, mais le nom
de famille de ma mère
était Giacobi,
elle était née à Corte.
C'est une part importante
de mon identité.
-Niagalé Giacobi,
c'est particulier.
-Exactement,
c'est tout aussi surprenant.
Mais ce qui est très important,
c'est que moi,
on m'a éduquée dans le respect
absolu de la France,
mais tout en me parlant
de mes autres origines.
Et je pense que le secret est là,
aujourd'hui,
c'est de connaître
ces deux histoires.
-Merci, Niagalé Bagayoko.
-Merci beaucoup.
Générique
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA